el presidente kazajo amenazó a los
manifestantes con la muerte el
mandatario ordenó al ejército disparar a
matar para hacer frente a los disturbios
en almaty y calificó de terroristas a
quienes protestan
qué tipo de negociaciones puede haber
con criminales con asesinos tuvimos que
lidiar con bandidos armados y entrenados
tanto locales como extranjeros eso es
bandidos y terroristas por eso hay que
destruirlos y eso se hará pronto también
el mandatario agradeció a china de
existan y turquía por su apoyo mientras
que rusia en 275 millones de transporte
militar con unidades del contingente de
paz de la organización del tratado de
seguridad colectiva
el grupo aéreo compuesto por más de 70
aviones y organizado por el ministerio
de defensa de rusia transporta durante
la última jornada a la parte rusa del
contingente de paz de la css a
kazajistán el portavoz agregó que los
militares rusos y la policía de
kazajistán retomaron el control del
aeropuerto de almaty pero si algunas
naciones han apoyado los beligerantes
declaraciones del mandatario kazajo en
europa el presidente de france por su
parte condenó la cacería de
manifestantes y dijo que seguiría
monitoreando la situación en la antigua
nación soviética
desde el primero de enero se han
registrado fuertes protestas en
kazajistán luego de que el gobierno
dejara de controlar los precios del
combustible lo que duplicó el precio del
gas licuado de uso común entre la
mayoría de los vehículos en la nación
petrolera además hay un descontento
generalizado en el país que ha estado
bajo un punto del mismo partido político
desde que se separó de la unión
soviética